okay today I'm going to talk to you
about distance time graphs now this is
the second video that I've made about
distance time graphs because this video
shows you a few more complex things that
you can do a distance time graph so for
the more basic stuff please watch the
other video so just a little reminder
first of all along the x-axis we always
have time and on the y-axis we always
have distance so we're going to have a
look at something slightly different
this time
so I'm going to make it look a little
bit more like this okay and then up to
there and then like this okay now this
is different from the from the graph I
drew in the first video because we've
got these curves instead and whenever
we've got a curve it tells us something
different now when we have an upwards
curve like this the object that's moving
is accelerating we have acceleration
that means it's getting faster because
as more time passes the amount of
distance covered increases with each
second so if we have an upwards curve
like this it shows acceleration just
like with the previous video whenever we
have a flat horizontal line like this in
a distance time graph it shows that the
object is stationary that means staying
still I can tell this because as time
passes we are not going any further so
it's staying at three meters in total
it's not going up not getting further so
it's stationary now this point here the
object starts moving again now but when
we have a line like this it shows
deceleration that means getting slower
as we can see here it starts off quite
steep so quite quickly and as it goes on
the amount as each second passes we're
going in decreasing amounts of distance
every single time so if we have a curve
like this we have deceleration which
means getting slower so what we can
actually do with with these curves
is there's a way to find the speed at an
at a particular point so let's say for
example I was trying to find the speed
of this moving object at eight seconds
now it's really difficult to do that if
it's a straight line it's quite easy to
find the tangent because all I need to
do is find my distance and my time which
is nice and easy if it's a straight line
however if there's a curve I need to do
something which is called drawing a
tangent so let's say I'm imagining I'm
trying to find how fast this object is
going at eight seconds what I need to do
is I need to go up to my line where
eight seconds is so at that point there
and I have to draw a straight line as
best I can
have to draw a straight line that shows
the speed at that particular point the
gradient at that particular point okay
it's quite difficult today but I think
I've managed it there okay so what I
then need to do is I need to make a
right angle triangle using that line so
it's going to look a bit like this so
what I've done is I've made a right
angle triangle now you can make that
triangle as big or as small as you want
I suggest we don't make it too small
because then it makes the measurements
less accurate so what I'd like what you
normally like to do is make them a
little bit bigger like this it's also
good if you can to try and use whole
numbers so try and kind of rather than
doing it three points to try and get it
exactly three just so it makes you mad a
little bit easier but they should work
it doesn't matter if if it is you know
three point five or three point two that
will work as well so what I'm trying to
do now is to recap it so I'm trying to
find the speed of this object at exactly
eight seconds I've drawn my tangent I've
made my my right angle triangle so now I
need to find the gradient of that line
and to find the grain of that line I
need to do speed equals distance over
time that should be at the speed equals
distance over time so my distance
traveled here let's have a look okay so
that if I just look over here I think
that distance is around
7.5 and so to find this distance is
traveled is 7.5 takeaway 3 because I'm
looking at this distance here I want to
find this part here so 7.5 take away 3
is 4.5 meters so that there is 4.5
meters now also I need to find my speed
I need to do distance divided by time so
my time is going to be between here and
here so my time is going to be between
10 second or 6 seconds and 10 seconds so
it's 4 seconds in total so at that point
it was traveling for point to find the
speed I need to do four point five my
distance divided by my time so I need to
be four point five divided by four which
equals one point one two five meters per
second so the very final thing I'm going
to show you how to do is just find the
average speed of this whole journey so
to find average speed of the whole
journey all we need to do is find your
final to find your final distance which
is seven meters
divide it by your time which is ten
seconds this one is 0.7 meters per
second is what we've done is we've just
find the average speed for this whole
journey so the only things we're
interested in is our final distance and
the amount of time to hold your only
took so that is how to do slightly more
complex things with distance time graphs
thank you